what do you get up to between takes on
sex i read the own team work for
examples a lot of these double fake outs
oh yeah a lot of pranking it was oh gosh
if that was 15 was reality show we would
be like move over Kardashians we would
be invest even our daily lives at
holland roden she is the most special
person I think that I mean and I mean
special in like every single aspect of
the word I've never met someone so
entertaining with this girl I've even be
reality show that unlike any other but
it's the same with with arrow arrows you
know we're all arrow is so busy it's
like everyone's you know I mean Steven
doesn't ever have a day off even to
think about anything so he's just busy
busy busy which is great because it
really sets a great precedent for the
rest of us but for the ones that you
know kind of come in and out we tend to
cause a little trouble sometimes it's
all in good fun what's the what's the
craziest thing you didn't save up on the
set of arrow the craziest thing that
I've done so far I have you know so I
actually the video didn't turn out very
good so I'm gonna have to I'm gonna use
some of the videos but I'm netted
together I uh and you obviously familiar
with ellen show ellen degeneres she does
up she does these dance stairs where you
know someone will be having a serious
conversation and you walk up behind them
and you do like a really funny dance and
you edit it to whatever song you you
want to I've done a few of those but I
really don't want to like pissing people
off and add it on without telling them
so i might have to tell them before i
put the video or you know I could Ellen
could just you know have me on the show
and zagging do it there so exactly I'm
gonna say that we could you know we
actually joke about how if we were
Harper was gonna find his parents this
year that we would reach out to Ellen
DeGeneres to to be my mom I like you
thinking I light you think we look quite
similar same features almost same
haircut and then you could do like a
little dance together yummy tough you
know I think she played great mother for
Roy Harper you retreated something that
someone said on Twitter the other day
someone had said that you
he was going to start Holland should
play Mary Jane in the amazing spider-man
movies now that we're not gonna have
shailene woodley and you know and
obviously you retweet it it so I'm
thinking y'all got a big thumbs up from
you so why do you think Holland would
make a good MJ you know there's some
rumors going around that they're there
that they you know could possibly going
alcohol be going out to Holland Roden so
do that which I don't know if it would
be replacing Mary Jane or if it would be
possibly playing another character hmm
but I think haulin I think haulin would
have been amazing choice I also i think
shaming Woodley's absolutely dividable
kids I you know obviously nothing again
starting she's such a talented person
and that performance and then you know
and the last poem she had done in
ascendance was soon i once i can almost
said divergent if that doesn't come out
yet um it was incredible but um I think
Holland is just she really fits the role
she really holland she's such a I mean
she does she need to get more credit
everything she does and we watch her on
Teen Wolf and she's just got so much
emotional depth but she's such a such an
amazing actress and I could I literally
could see how and being like the next
week Reese Witherspoon she's got so much
character and she works really hard for
it so I I would love her to see her do
that kazoo you know it did show the rest
of the world mr. with what she can
actually do
you